tu es l'honneur des gueules noires vous
pouvez bien sûr réagir à ce documentaire
sur le hashtag docu débat c'est un
documentaire réalisé par vous aux gens
du créneau bienvenue à vos côtés
stéphane sirot bonjour vous êtes
historien spécialiste du syndicalisme
enseignant à l'université de cergy
pontoise en face de vous jérôme sainte
marie bonjour je vous êtes politologue
président fondateur de pôle inbox et
enfin dominique watrin de bienvenue vous
êtes sénateur communiste du pas de
calais alors jean luc raynaud on quitte
vos protagonistes
en 2012 ils sont inquiets après le
recours en cassation de la mise de
l'économie de l'époque christine lagarde
que s'est il passé depuis le procès
était cassée comme on pouvait s'y
attendre c'était il y aura une audace
incroyable sur le plan juridique ils ont
été soutenus aussi par un collectif
d'avocats qui était très très motivés et
bon à s'attaquer à la prescription 60
ans après c'était quand même très
audacieux or le problème de la cour de
cassation ce qu'elle juge pas sur le
fond et qui évidemment ça a été cassé le
problème c'était pourquoi la ministre de
l'époque donc madame lagarde s'est
permis c pourvoir en cassation c'était
ça la question votre film il a donné
lieu à ce que vous appelez un miracle la
mise la justice christiane taubira a
décidé au nom de la république de
réparer le préjudice l'injustice suivi
par les mineurs de 48 en légiférant une
loi plutôt qu'un jugement c'est plus
fort oui symboliquement puisque déjà
pour moi j'ai fait ce film pour qu'il
ait une valeur symbolique rendre leur
honneur à ceux qui l'ont perdu c'est le
règne vraie motivation pour moi en tant
que cinéaste mais c'est aussi ce que ces
jours là pendant 60 ans réclamés donc
c'est fort donc oui loi c'est plus fort
que le jugement sauf que là avec la
prescription le jugement était
qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à traiter la
grève de 48 cm motifs personnels
oui non
je ne suis pas du tout de la région mais
par contre oui cette histoire là m'a
beaucoup touché sur le plan humain
puisqu'il s'agit davantage d'une
histoire qui dure 60 ans et qu'elle sur
plusieurs générations et que donc ils
apprennent de transmission
quelque chose qui a été traumatique a
été vécu par ces mineurs on va le film
vient de le montrer et c'est surtout été
transmis de manière presque inconsciente
à leurs descendants à leur enfant dans
le film il ya un personnage qui n'a pas
pu faire ça sa carrière parce que son
père avait été emprisonné donc voilà il
ya à titre personnel c'est ça c'est
l'ars et ses fils qui doivent payer pour
la faute
de leurs pairs faute que leur père n'ont
même pas comme lice alors c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire la
république française que l'état
reconnaît ses torts
vis-à-vis d'ouvriers qui ont fait grève
oui bien si c'est une première ça on
peut être fier pas seulement moi mais
tous ceux qui se sont battus les avocats
les 17 familles de mineurs et en plus la
loi un avantage sur la ce jury d'x sur
la sur la sur la sur le jugement c'est
que c'est ouvert à tous et même ceux qui
n'étaient pas dans la procédure ont
droit il suffit qu'il fasse valoir leurs
droits donc là sur le plan quantifiable
la loi est très supérieur au jugement
est alors la ministre est allé plus loin
puisqu'elle a décidé d'inscrire la grève
des mineurs de 48 dans les livres
d'histoire ce qui n'était pas le cas
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour vous et
pour les familles de mineurs ces terres
que cet épisode de l'histoire française
dans les livres à l'école ça c'était le
sujet du film c'est là tout avait été
aux fruits c'était il fallait exhumé
c'était aussi le désir du film et on
exhume ce qui a été oublié quelque chose
de traumatique qui a été vécu par eux et
donc réparation de ça et le fait que
comment dire s'il faut parler
transmission c'est exactement ça donc il
faut que ça soit transmis quelque chose
ne s'est pas transmis entre ses pairs
vaincu et ses fils pendant les histoires
de mise et ses filles puisqu'il ya une
place très importante donnée aux femmes
aussi dans cette lutte donc le fait de
passer par effectivement le
l'école par la transmission officielle
la wii sur le plan symbolique sur la
réparation symbolique cela me semble
extrêmement important après comment
c'est possible de le faire de maître
dans les programmes scolaires à
l'histoire cette grève l'importance et
comme elle était totalement ignoré
le faire savoir l'a révélé et la réparer
les deux à la fois c'est très fort donc
il ya eu rétablissement dans la c'est à
dire cette loi et cette décision tout ça
d'un ministre pour ça je parle de
miracle parce que on est tombé sur la
bonne personne au bon moment c'est
normalement ce n'aurait jamais dû moi
j'étais persuadé en faisant le film
commencerait rester à la koala cassation
et donc on aurait fait le film sorte de
victoire symbolique ou plutôt deux
défaites
deux défaites et victoires en même temps
enfin bon on n'y croyait pas beaucoup
voilà donc rétablissement dans la
dignité pour ces hommes qui ont été
atteints dans leur honneur
rétablissement dans l'égalité puisque
c'est une histoire de discrimination
c'est très important aussi puisque
pourquoi eux et pas les autres et
rétablissement dans la mémoire
collective peut-être ça le plus
important même si après on peut comment
on va faire ça dans les programmes
scolaires c'est autre chose les
applications vos réactions à ce
documentaire je veux bien commencé sur
deux points alors d'abord c'est une
belle histoire de persévérance puisque
c'était un peu là dessus vous étiez vous
étiez parti c'est quelque chose de tout
à fait inédit on n'a jamais vu une telle
continuité dans la volonté d'être
réhabilité suite à un mouvement social
suite à des faits de grève on a d'autres
exemples dans l'histoire de grévistes
révoqué je pense par exemple aux
cheminots et 1920 suite à cette grève
18me cheminots révoqué qui sont
réintégrés en 24 par cas le cartel des
gauches mais sanaa ça n'a rien à voir
c'est sans commune mesure avec cette
entreprise qui effectivement est portée
très largement par des volontés
personnel comme celle de norbert gilmez
et qui reste aujourd'hui on le voit bien
cet événement de 48 un marqueur
important pour la cgt il ya quelques
jours filent martinez le nouveau
secrétaire général de la cgt s'est rendu
dans le nord pas de calais il a
rencontré dans norbert gilmez le
deuxième point c'est celui sur les
manuels scolaires là j'avoue que en tant
qu'enseignant je suis un peu dubitatif
sur sur la manière dont ça pourrait être
appliquée
donc quoi pourquoi parce que d'abord je
dirais surtout quand on feuillette des
manuels scolaires du collège ou du lycée
les mouvements sociaux les grands
mouvements sociaux du xxème siècle en
général ont plutôt tendance à
disparaître donc je m'interroge sur la
manière dont on va réintroduire celui-ci
peut-être que effectivement si l'a77
vertu de réintroduire d'autres grands
mouvements sociaux du xxème siècle comme
le front populaire comme mai juin 68 qui
ont un peu disparu voire très largement
disparu de l'enseignement et des manuels
scolaires ça serait intéressant mais
j'attends de voir puisqu'en ce moment
d'ailleurs les programmes d histoire
géographie du collège sont en train
d'être discutés pour le moment je n'ai
pas entendu quoi que ce soit sur deux 46
et la mythologie des mines donc il ya
quelque chose là de romantique si je
puis dire ingénierie tout ça dans le
fait que ça peut peut-être parler aux
jeunes générations quoi surtout de celle
de cette région là bien sûr son
ignorance du passé de l'ordre de leurs
paroles notre part m moi ce que je
retiens c'est d'abord c'est une grande
victoire pour des sommes qui auraient
été
marqué toute leur vie et des femmes
aussi leurs épouses qui ont été non
seulement licenciés mais chassés de
leurs logements privés de tous les
enfants privés de bourse etc etc donc
c'est une grande victoire morale c'est
l'honneur qui est rétabli pour une
corporation entière et je crois qu'il ya
un travail de mémoire et la chaîne de
mémoire peut reprendre grâce à cette
réhabilitation c'est extrêmement
important de rappeler que la force des
mineurs force de frappe parce qu'à
l'époque 48 pas de charbon pas
d'industrie c'est une période
particulièrement difficile mais force
morale aussi de la corporation minière
qui a toujours
mis de côté son intérêt ou les intérêts
individuels derrière l'intérêt
patriotique et la montrer et on parle de
la transmission de l'histoire est
important de dire sont presque les mêmes
qui sont les mineurs de 48 qui étaient
en grève en 41 face à l'occupant nazi
avec leur femme également qu'ils ont
manifesté dans la rue avec beaucoup de
courage et on va en
fait j'avais la pression d'un premier
abord que ce film était un peu
intempestives c'est à dire que c'était
quelque chose qui était un peu hors du
temps en fait en y réfléchissant
davantage pas vraiment il ya
actuellement et on l'a vu lors la
campagne présidentielle de 2012 on a
énormément parlé du monde ouvrier il y
actuellement un retour important de
l'opinion publique et des politiques sur
la question ouvrière qui est lié à la
question de l'industrie lisation plus
précisément de la désindustrialisation
du pays il ya peut-être aussi le fait
qu'aujourd'hui la classe ouvrière n'est
pas ressentie d'une part son existence
même est mise en question et elle n'est
pas ressenti comme un danger politique
ce qu'elle était évidemment à l'époque
et tout l'enjeu à mon avis quand on se
penche sur cette histoire là c'est de
voir qu actuelle à l'époque les pour la
confrontation était dur pas seulement
parce que le pouvoir était méchant mais
aussi tout simplement parce qu'il y
avait un enjeu politique nationale et
internationale qui était bien réel
aujourd'hui si j'ose dire ça coûte moins
cher à l'état de se pencher avec
compassion sur cette saison alors
justement va y revenir parce que la
grève de quarante-huit donc reste
la grève des mineurs la plus importante
du 20e siècle a pu réprimer six morts
des milliers d'arrestations 1342
condamnés à la prison ferme dont 700
dans le nord pas de calais pour
comprendre l'ampleur de cette grève et
la brutalité de sa répression faut
revenir sur le contexte d'après-guerre
la seconde guerre
mondiale est terminée mais la guerre
froide elle commence on réécoute un
extrait du documentaire
c'est ici que le 26 mai 1941 les mineurs
entrèrent en grève moi en 1941 j'étais
un jeune pendant la grève je venais de
descendre au fond nous étions des gamins
mais des gamins de la génération du
front populaire très combatif et on a
fait grève deux heures nous les galibots
15 ans pour obtenir du savon on n'a rien
obtenu mais enfin on avait quand même
montré qu'on était là alors si cet homme
évoque l'occupant allemand c'est parce
que en 1941 en pleine occupation 100000
grévistes s'étaient déjà soulevé pendant
13 jours des mineurs qui avaient alors
été réprimées très brutalement par les
soldats nazis 250 déportés sans fusillé
donc en 1948 quand le ministre de
l'intérieur je me moque envoie l'armée
plus 60000 crs les mitraillettes contre
ces mêmes gueules noires c'est un
souvenir très violent quoi qui remonte
oui alors pour remettre un tout cette
grève dans son compte est je dirais
qu'il faut voir trois niveaux vous
l'avez dit le niveau international on
est on est en pleine guerre froide et au
moment où se déroule cette grève des
mineurs deux 48 se déroule aussi au plan
international la première crise de
berlin il ya le coup de prague qui vient
d'avoir lieu en tchécoslovaquie
donc on a un contexte international qui
est qui est extrêmement tendue qui se
répercute aussi sur le deuxième niveau
qui est le niveau national depuis mai 47
les ministres communistes sont sortis ou
ont été chassés comme on voudra du du
gouvernement et donc je dirais que ça a
libéré toute une série de tensions et de
revendications sociales qui jusque là
avait été largement
maintenue
sous une certaine chape de plomb par le
parti communiste via via la cgt on a un
gouvernement donc en 48 qui est 100
ministres communistes et ou à deux
postes clés il y a deux socialistes qui
sont effectivement jules moch à
l'intérieur qui était déjà là lors des
grèves de 47 parce qu'il faut se
souvenir aussi qu'à l'hiver 47 ya des
grèves qui chez les mineures mais plus
largement au plan national sont aussi
des grèves très violente et qui sont
violemment réprimées aussi où on assiste
à des scènes quasiment des scènes de
guerre j'allais dire et on a déjà jules
moch à ce moment là donc on a de ces
deux postes clés l'intérieur jules moch
et l'industrie robert lacoste donc deux
je dirais de deux socialistes qui font
plutôt partie de la frange
la plus atlantiste et la plus anti
communiste de la sf bio de cette époque
et qui sont près d'une certaine manière
à en découdre jules moch a mis en place
au printemps 48 des espèces de super
préfet qui sont destinés à coordonner
l'éventuelle intervention des forces de
l'ordre en cas de conflit tirant les
enseignements de celui de 47 et puis
elle troisième niveau qui essuient de la
profession minière qui n'est pas
n'importe laquelle vous l'avez dit a eu
la grève de 41 il y à aussi à la tête du
parti communiste quelqu'un qui s'appelle
maurice thorez donc le mineur la figure
du mineur c'est aussi la grande figure
j'irai du mouvement ouvrier de l'après
guerre donc c'est quelque chose de très
sensible le monde de la mine et puis il
ya des problèmes sociaux qui
effectivement sont majeures il ya eu des
décrets lacoste qui ont conduit à
prendre des décisions consistant à
baisser de 10% l'emploi au jour et dans
l'est dans le secteur administratif qui
ont réduit les prérogatives des délégués
mineurs qui ont également transférer la
gestion des risques des risques
professionnels et des accidents aux
houillères plutôt qu' aucune société de
secours mutuel des mines ça qui est
effectivement c'est un sujet sensible
parce que la profession minière c'est
une profession aussi à risque et donc
évidemment le transférer série c'est
plus que ça à des structures qui ne sont
pas des structures gérées par les les
élus des démineurs c'est quelque chose
qui effectivement est extrêmement
sensible donc à une forme de deux fêtes
d'éléments qui peut être perçue comme
une provocation à l'égard de cette
profession minière
devrait insister sur la dimension
politique est là dans la mémoire que ces
événements vont avoir au fond c'est
largement à un affrontement entre
communistes et socialistes tu as fait
c'est un petit peu l'équivalent pour la
france de ce qu'a été les événements en
1919 la répression du mouvement
spartakiste par les corps francs
allemand avec l'aide de la social
démocratie allemande pour la mémoire la
mémoire sociale en allemagne et cette
division très profondes qui auront des
conséquences dramatiques en allemagne
entre les deux pôles et deux éléments de
la gauche en france et ce que l'on
constaté dans la mémoire collective
communiste 7 ces événements là vont être
très dures il est plein d'équivalent en
pareil cas situation allemande y compris
l'utilisation ostensible de l'armée et
je crois que cette ça entraîne pour le
parti communiste un isolement par
rapport au reste de la gauche qui va
durer au moins symboliquement jusqu'au à
une autre grève celle-ci réussissait le
franc 63 qui elle va être un peu un
désenclavement quelque sorte des
communistes au sein de la gauche oui je
suis pas pour nier la division entre
socialistes et communistes dans le
bassin minier qui perdure manière
atténuée je vous rassure aujourd'hui
mais qui existe est effectivement
simplement je crois qu'il ya une
dimension qui n'a pas été donnée ici
c'est que les décrets lacoste et ce qui
est fait aux mineurs en 48 c'est un peu
la rupture du contrat qui est passé à la
libération elle est c'est à dire la
bataille du charbon à la production mais
en échange du statut du mineur est avec
cette idée que plus on va produire plus
il y aura davantage sociaux parce que la
situation des mineurs extrêmement dur 80
% des enfants qui sont rachitiques mais
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord pour
dire que localement et sur toute cette
région pour dire qu'il y avait une
division at elle à ce poids là puisque
bien sûr le gouvernement réprime et
fortement cette grève et manière tout à
fait disproportionnée mais je peux citer
des exemples de municipalités
socialistes qui sont venus faire la
solidarité en direction des grévistes
par exemple la municipalité
billy montigny qui offrait des repas aux
mineurs grévistes donc c'était pas vécu
en bas pas comme une grève
insurrectionnelle pas du tout ce qui est
frappant est paradoxal dans ce la
répression de cette grève c'est qu'on
ait tiré sur ceux qui quelques années
plus tôt avait défendu la france contre
les nazis les mineurs étant parti
communiste mais il était aussi d'anciens
officiers ou ce sous-officier de la
résistance et parmi les humiliations
subies il ya ce que les mineurs appelle
le déshonneur suprême cerqueux at elle
des honneurs qu'ils n'ont même pas
parler à leur famille ils ont gardé
secret entre c'est à dire qu'on les a
dégradé pourquoi l etat et l'armée est
allé jusque là un véritable acharnement
est très impressionnant il y avait la
charge d'un nom de jules moch qui était
donc qu'on vient de dire un
anticommunisme viscéral à c'était lors
du ces c'est un fantasme c'est à dire il
était persuadé quand même que c'était le
kominform qui avait organisé et en plus
c'était quand on pense en fait la raison
d'état est invoquée on pense que c'est
une infraction qu'il ensuite intégré la
ghost comme comme on a dit c'est la pure
provocation enfin je dirais n'était
prémédité ils savaient qu'ils auraient
grève et il savait donc qu'il avait
préparé en recréant les i gamme qui sont
des préfets qui ont le pouvoir sur
l'armée sur la police et la gendarmerie
chose qui ne s'est jamais reproduite à
la république feront dans l'histoire de
la république française il savait qu'il
allait y avoir pensé à tout ça était
parfaitement prémédité
je dirais prolongée ce qui vient d'être
dit qu'il effectue une véritable volonté
de châtier oui voilà on veut on veut
châtié une prophétie est effectivement
c'est parce que c'est par la symbolique
au fond qu'on chatila commises en
profondeur quant aux grèves
insurrectionnelles puisque le mot a été
a été prononcée de trois fois c'est
effectivement l'argument que va utiliser
tout au long de sa vie jules moch déjà
il avait utilisé en 1947 les services du
ministère de l'intérieur eux mêmes
avaient produit des rapports quelques
mois plus tard en disant qu'il avait
beaucoup sur estimé
cet éventuel cet éventuel danger
mais il ya une volonté aussi draps de
dramatiser voilà quand on regarde les
actualités de l'époque autour de cette
grève de quarante-huit qui donne parfois
l'image d'ailleurs de scènes de guerre
on a l'impression qu'on est encore sous
sous l'occupation et il ya une volonté
de la part du pouvoir qui contrôle très
largement la télévision de créer une
espèce de dramaturgie autour de ce
conflit et donc d' instrumentaliser cet
argument insurrectionnel pour justifier
cet emploi que monsieur qualifier tout à
l'heure de disproportionné de la force
effectivement il faut il faut voir qu'il
y a si on rapporte ça au nombre de
grévistes à un militaire ou un crs pour
quatre grévistes c'est ça la réalité de
2,7 de cette répression de la grève de
quarante-huit donc effectivement c'est
on est dans le châtiment je vire la
fameuse expression crs ss pas cessé de
les re dit dans le film vient de 1948
contrairement à tout ce que les gens
croient qu'il ya de 68 à bien dollars
pourquoi parce que justement ce que je
parle des traumatismes tout à l'heure
c'est cette répétition le fait qu'ils
aient été
réprimé à la fois par les nazis en 41 et
en sept ans plus tard c'était souvent
les mêmes et là et même un des
personnages de mon film pierrot bouliac
et un fils son père a été déporté en 41
emprisonnés et ensuite en 48 il a fait
la grève et lui a été en prison alors
ils cherchent et lui justement un grand
besoin de réhabilitation mais que son
père soit réhabilité militairement
parlant situations
où il voit un autre aspect très
intéressant dans cet ouvrage est qu un
peu collatéral mais qui m'a qui
m'intéresse en tant que pour l'opinion
contemporaine
c'est la mémoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale et ses suites c'est à dire que
c'est vrai que ça permet de revenir sur
ces mouvements importants de 42,41
pardon mais juin 41 et ça permet de
désenclaver un petit peu la mémoire la
fnaut 1 mondial qui est complètement
aujourd'hui chez les jeunes générations
complètement occupé par les à la fois la
geste héroïque de quelques maquis qui
sont en fait un tout petit élément de la
résistance et puis par la shoah là ça
rappelle que il ya effectivement c'est
cette réalité sociale une ré d'une micro
résistance en tout cas pas quelque chose
d'héroïque avec des vers et des
mitraillettes et des sapins derrière
mais quelque chose qui soutient beaucoup
plus proche de la réalité le second
point aussi par rapport à 7
la compréhension qu'ont souvent beaucoup
de gens pour pourquoi est ce que toute
une série de personnes compromises
pendant la guerre ont été maintenus à la
tête de l'administration dans les
fonctions importantes de l'état on pense
bien sûr à papon et bien c'est aussi
qu'il y avait un besoin de l'état dans
l'après-guerre pas face au nouvel ennemi
qui était le communisme international
donc ça explique aussi cette continuité
c'est permet de restituer à mon avis les
enjeux sociaux et politiques réelles de
l'époque
aujourd'hui soixante ans plus tard alors
que le parti communiste n'a plus la
présence le poids qu'il avait à l'époque
la gauche prenne à représenter les
classes populaires quand le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui socialiste décide de
revenir sur l'histoire de réparer une
injustice faite à la classe ouvrière que
faut-il y voir est ce que c'est un
symbole ou est-ce que c'est plus que ça
le matin je pense qu' il peut y avoir
une continuité mais nous sommes dans une
dans une situation complètement
différente
il faut quand même se rappeler qu'il y
avait une unité très forte entre le lieu
de travail et le lieu de résidence que
c'est le maire de ma commune qui
aujourd'hui décédé qui me le rappelait
le jour de paye les s'étaient tous les
quinze jours les ouvriers venaient à la
salle des fêtes les mineurs et ils
encaissaient la paye y donnaient leurs
cotisations au syndicat cgt et puis
aller à la troisième étape qui était la
cotisation du parti communiste donc
voilà il y avait une unité de lieu une
unité idéologique une unité forte et
aujourd'hui on est dans de tout autres
conditions puisque vous rappelle que sur
ce secteur du bassin minier et notamment
sur le secteur d'hénin beaumont dont on
parle par ailleurs il ya eu deux mille
cinq cents licenciements 2500 pertes
d'emplois directs et indirects suite à
trois fermetures d usines et que la
carte du front national et correspond à
la carte de la désindustrialisation et
du chômage et donc on est dans une toute
autre situation ça on va y revenir vous
vouliez agir stéphane sirot sur le
symbole oui sur le symbole et puis
surtout ce que j'étais en train
d'entendre parce qu'effectivement ça on
n'en a pas parlé mais quand un mineur
est licencié et hyper tous sains et à un
moment donné lorsque gilles messe dit
j'ai bien aimé
il est condamné à vie alors quand il dit
qu'il est condamné à vie condamné à la
fois à chercher à être réhabilité les
condamnés à vie au sens où effectivement
on perd sa vie quand on perd son emploi
la mine on perd son logement on perd
l'école des enfants on peut plus
retrouver ou très difficilement un
travail dans ce bassin minier où les
ouvrières sont extrêmement puissante où
l'emploi est très concentré donc voilà
c'est une espèce de mise en exil des des
individus qui sont concernés
effectivement moral et voilà je te les
charbonnages téléphoner chaque fois que
des emprisonnés cherche à trouver du
travail avait téléphoné pour nom
celui-là vous le promets bon ils m'ont
tous dit ça c'est une réalité donc il ya
un acharnement de cet état dans l'état
qui étaient les charbonnages de france
le choix qui est aussi un enjeu
symbolique particulier au fait qu' on
est dans le coeur symbolique de la
classe ouvrière c'est à dire grille agit
des mineurs l'ours est pas seule figure
1 je crois dans l'après guerre le parti
communiste est beaucoup insisté sur la
figure du métallo aussi non enfin le
mineur c'est important j'apporte et le
livre de maurice thorez la fif du peuple
dans lequel il ya une photo de maurice
thorez 147 les dix présents du conseil
et il est là amitié à la m habiller en
mineur avec le costume très très peu et
très particulier de l'époque cette
figure du mineur est importante parce
qu'elle permet effectivement à tous ceux
qui sont vives autour de la mine aussi
reconnaître et c'est quand même dans
l'histoire de france une figure très
valorisé ne serait ce que par l'oeuvre
d'emile zola germinal c'est quelqu'un
qui dont on connaît les souffrances
qu'ils s'exposent qui fait un métier qui
est à peine concevable en fait et donc
c'est vraiment à la fois le coeur la
classe ouvrière mais même le choeur
souffrent de la classe ouvrière aux yeux
de l'opinion en général alors si le
xxème siècle en marche par don marque la
fin du monde un monde avec la fermeture
des mines la désindustrialisation du
pays le monde ouvrier
combien même modifié est toujours là
mais est ce que la classe politique
aurait eu tendance à l'oublier on écoute
un nouvel extrait du documentaire quand
la cour de cassation aura rendu son
jugement
combien restera-t-il de survivants parmi
les 17 hommes et femmes qui se font
porter devant la justice comme il
restera t-il il y en a déjà un moins lui
qu'un de mes frères et moore ça c'est
une rente est contre parce que cette
même christine lagarde a
largement sucre et bernard tapie 400
mille quatre cent mille euros je crois
et pour les 30000 euros 45 millions
d'euros quand bien 45 millions d'euros
de 45 millions d'euros de préjudice
moral oui il est mort
voilà en vie dans un pays
de classe
la désindustrialisation la
spécialisation des ouvriers ont-elles
entraîné la fin de la lutte des classes
ou pas
j'ai envie de rentrer à paris je crois
le milliardaire américain buffett qui
déclarait récemment la lutte des classes
existe et d'ailleurs nous l'avons gagnée
non ce qui est certain c'est ce qui a
changé c'est à la fois l'aspect
quantitatif de du monde ouvrier mais
également justement la conscience que
mon ouvrier à lui même alors expliquant
sciatique s'est donnée quelques
pourcentages il y avait 37 % d'ouvriers
à la population active en 1981 il n'ya
plus que 23 % aujourd'hui à 23 % c'est
beaucoup moins mais c'est quand même un
c'est quand même un actif sur quatre en
réalité c'est beaucoup plus que les
cadres supérieurs par exemple qui eux
sont représentés à la télévision qui
sont représentés au parlement qui sont
représentées dans les publicités qui
sont valorisés alors que mon ouvrier
symboliquement lui a disparu et
remarquablement absent des deux
assemblées par ailleurs ce qui est le
voudra en venir c'est que quand on
demande et ça c'est très différent par
rapport à autre fois c'est quand on
demande aux gens est ce qu'ils ont
l'impression de faire partie d'une
classe sociale ces exemples-là qu elle
est bien aujourd'hui plus vous êtes here
are chic mans élevé social dans la
société plus vous avez le sentiment de
faire partie d'une classe sociale a
conscience de classe existe mais c'est
d'abord les cadres qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui d'après un sondage de l'ifop
pour fondapol d'ailleurs est bien seul
un quart des riez on déclare se sentir
faire partie de la classe ouvrière alors
après il ya un autre là dessus c'est une
construction à plusieurs c'est la faute
de la société c'est aussi le fait que
autrefois
m'adresse à mon voisin est bien le parti
communiste qui se définissait comme le
parti des classes ouvrières s'est défini
ensuite tout comme le parti des gens il
ya plus d'un an plus une expression
unifiée politiquement de ce monde
ouvrier en tout cas le logo revenir
c'est moins d'ouvriers mais surtout
beaucoup beaucoup moins de conscience de
classe
toujours dans la fidélité aux valeurs
défendues par les mineurs mais je pense
qu'il ya une continuité du parti
communiste de ce point de vue alors
rappellerai que nous nous sommes fidèles
encore au programme national à
résistance sur la maîtrise publique de
l'économie sur les acquis sociaux qui
sont aujourd'hui remis en cause les uns
après les autres la difficulté c'est ce
que j'ai dit c'est que la classe
ouvrière existe toujours peut-être un
peu moins quantitativement elle s'est
surtout diversifier et nous avons à
faire je disais à la fermeture sur ce
territoire d'hénin beaumont dont je
parlais à l'instance de 2500 emplois
perdus et il ya eu effectivement
d'autres emplois créés notamment dans
les services mais il ya un sentiment
généralisé d'abandon de déclassement qui
profite plus à la colère noire qu'a la
colère rouge et c'est ça la difficulté
mais nous sommes fidèles et nous nous
battons je peux vous assurer dans la les
valeurs des démineurs est si important
pour nous que cette cette histoire soit
rappelé oui je voudrais juste a ajouté
que pour pour se sentir faire classe il
faut aussi se sentir
représenté en tant que tel et ça ça a
été effectivement un moment donné la
grande réussite du parti communiste qui
a effectivement au travers de figures
comme thorez et d'autres qui a réussi à
être le porte parole de cette classe
ouvrière en tant que tel aujourd'hui
quand on regarde à la fois la
représentation politique
combien d'ouvriers j'allais dire pas
combien de divisions mais combien
d'ouvrir si vous remet mais c'est un peu
le même problème aussi qu'on retrouve
d'ailleurs ce décalage entre
représentants et représentés qu'on
trouve d'une certaine manière aussi dans
le mouvement syndical parce que quand on
regarde la composition des syndicats
aujourd'hui il ya trois fois plus de
techniciens et cadres que d'ouvriers
quand on regarde les taux de
syndicalisation
et donc il ya ce décalage qui ce qui
existe entre la sociologie du monde du
travail et la sociologie politique et
même sociale qu'est ce que j'avais
besoin c'est de qui on parle aujourd'hui
quand on emploie le mot d'ouvriers
ouvriers c'est le travail posté c'est le
travail en usine ça peut être aussi un
travail plus qualifiés effectivement le
travail ouvrier lui même s'est beaucoup
transformé ses pulls ou sc plus loin ce
traditionnel dont il y avait évidemment
ça ça joue sans doute aussi dans la
manière dont s'opère ce dont on se
perçoit soi même et puis je dirais que
l'ouvrier n'est pas forcément
révolutionnaire en tant que tel et son
aspiration c'est plutôt l'ascenseur
social et donc il peut aussi dans ce
cadre là se sentir ou espérer appartenir
plutôt à une autre classe que celle à
laquelle effectivement en terme de deux
mondes du travail il appartient
réellement un facteur de génération
aussi dans tout ça un ouvrier qui est né
dans les années 30 où dans les années 70
c'est pas le même contexte politique
c'est pas le même héritage on parle de
transmission tout à l'heure
il ya eu un échec d'autres solutions
comme par hasard puisqu'on parlait d'un
moment tout à l'heure même le fief de
marine le pen oui et envahit la carte
des élections par te mentale à 100 que
ceux d'hier le nord est devenu terroir
si je puis dire désolé du front national
mais est-ce que ça fait quand même
incroyable arcand 48 c'était le concept
est rouge de ferrou jean veil on va
essayer de comprendre mais ce que ça
veut dire que que les ouvriers
aujourd'hui sont porteurs de questions
nouvelles de problèmes nouveaux de
questions nouvelles avant de voir
l'aspect strictement politique mais sur
l'aspect social qu'est ce qu'on appelle
effectivement un ouvrier vit et où la
beatlemania 23% la population active il
faut rajouter immédiatement deux choses
si on ne prend que les ouvriers d'usiné
d'industrie il n'y en a plus que 13% en
fait sur les 23 % il ya dix ans il ya là
presque la moitié ces ouvriers qui sont
dans l'est dans les services qui sont
dispersés or quand on n'est plus
contrairement justement à ce qui se
passait dans les mines ou là les gens
vivaient ensemble ils vénèrent un
regroupement de fait et donc toutes les
activités culturelles collective etc qui
en découle est donc une conscience qui
se faisait d'elle même a aujourd'hui
l'ouvrier français est souvent dispersés
il est dispersé également parce qu'on
trouve beaucoup d'emplois dans les
instituts de sondage si vous voulez vous
avez deux ou trois personnes qui sont
d'un point de vue une c'est qu'ils sont
des ouvriers mais qui sont évidemment
qu'ils ne peuvent pas développer cette
conscience de classe particulière où la
conscience d'intérêt 10 ont un intérêt
commun et puis un autre un deuxième
aspect social qui joue très fortement
c'est que c'est quand même la population
la plus exposée au risque de chômage et
donc vous avez ça qui fait que ce qui
dès qu'ils également a tendance à
tétaniser et quand vous êtes menacés
directement du chômage et bien forcément
voulait moins tendance à vous exposer en
militant dernière chose peut être aussi
c'est aussi une population qui était
largement recomposé c'était déjà le cas
à l'époque c'est toujours le cas par les
phénomènes migratoires
historiquement la gestion du monde
ouvrier au sein de la gauche a été
l'apanage du parti communiste
aujourd'hui les socialistes ont des
difficultés à représenter l'ensemble de
la gauche par exemple quand le
syndicaliste edouard martin choisit de
mener la liste ps dans la région grand
est aux européennes ses camarades sont
nombreux à crier à la trahison pas à
cause de son engagement politique mais
parce qu'il choisit la couleur ps d'où
vient cette défiance à l'égard du parti
socialiste au millimètre un bon je crois
que les choses sont claires en tout cas
sur la dernière période puisque et on
peut parler de trahison et c'est comme
ça que c'est ressenti dans mon
territoire
l'arrivée de françois hollande elle est
le fait qu'ils tournent le dos à des
engagements qu'il avait pu prendre
notamment bourget ccvq strictement comme
ça et c'est pour ça je parlais d'un
sentiment d'abandon en même temps que
sentiment de déclassement parce que ces
emplois industriels qui étaient
concentrées qui permettait justement la
lutte syndicale et politique et qui
permettait d'avoir des acquis
l'affaiblissement du parti communiste a
été une de cause de ce déclassement sap
était une bonne chose et le la montée du
front national et une mauvaise aussi je
le dis très clairement eh bien il ya ce
sentiment là et aussi je pense que il ya
eu une volonté de l'état à travers cette
histoire d de plusieurs dizaines
d'années de mettre fin à ces forteresses
ouvrir les mines mais aussi d'autres
forces reste et si vous regardez le
parcours d'un jeune j'entends dans le
film achille blondeau qualité
secrétaires la fédération nationale cgt
des mines c'est très bien de quoi il
parle et 10 nous en 48 nous étions les
enfants 36 aujourd'hui les jeunes à qui
le parti communiste affaires qui sont
précarisées qui sont disséminés qui sont
pu regrouper mais sont aussi les enfants
d'un enseignement de l'économie libérale
et qu'il est très difficile de pompe à
vous parler d'un abandon spencer de
quand date le déclin du vote ouvrier
vers le parti communiste ou vers la
gauche et à partir de quand on en a pris
vraiment conscience alors ça peut être
qu'il faudrait davantage demander aux
politiques mais je voudrais quand même
répondre en partie à votre votre
question je crois que une partie de la
désertion des ouvriers à l'égard des
partis de gauche parce que c'est vrai
pour le parti socialiste c'est vrai
aussi pour le parti communiste il ya
toute une série d'éléments mais je pense
que notamment la distanciation prise par
la gauche en général aussi bien sous
forme partisane que sous forme syndicale
d'un certain nombre de thématiques je
pense à la thématique de l'état de la
nation d'un nationalisation de la
protection qu'ils sont devenus dans le
discours dominant des thématiques
ringarde
c'est quelque chose et qui ont été
reprises bien sûr par par le front
national quand on entend certains de ses
responsables de florian philippot par
exemple on a l'impression parfois en
mettant des guillemets qu'on a à faire
un dirigeant syndical d'il ya 30 ou 40
ans parce qu'effectivement le front
national a repris ses thématiques
qu'aujourd'hui la gauche a peur de de
creuser et de reprendre à son compte
parce qu'elle craint cette cette espèce
de ringardisation vers laquelle on peut
le renvoyer pour pour revenir une
dernière chose sur ce qui était évoqué
la volonté de d'éclater en quelque sorte
les forteresses ouvrière ça a
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
existe est d'ailleurs puisqu'on parlait
tout à l'heure de robert lacoste dès les
années 48 50 on a des propos de la cause
dès 1950 qui parle de la future
extinction d des mines avait de
l'employé jérôme sainte-marie en 95 30 %
des ouvriers avaient voté jean marie le
pen lors de la présidentielle est ce que
à ce moment là où 95 on se on se dit pas
que quelque part il ya un souci sur la
représentation des ouvriers ma question
c'est parce que on peut s'interroger sur
la réflexion de la gauche comme de la
droite est ce qu'on n'a pas délaissé des
thématiques sociales au profit de
thématiques plus sociétale je pense à
des rapports fiables et non pas
seulement il ya des choses compliquées
dans la vie politique et chose très
simple la qui est vraiment très simple
on part dans les années 70 à peu près
sept ouvriers sur dix qui aux élections
vote pour les partis de gauche 68% par
exemple au lycée 1913 et en 81 encore je
crois que 72% des ouvriers qui vote pour
françois mitterrand au second tour 7 sur
10 et après ça dégringole très
rapidement il ya deux élections
essentiellement on voit dégringolé
l'alignement à gauche nouveaux ouvriers
ses 86 donc fin de la première période
mitterrand où il est vraiment pouvoir et
93 fin de la seconde période 8e rang
c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est la go
quand la gauche est au pouvoir
et même chose pour d'ailleurs pour pour
2002 également avec là aussi avec
l'effondrement du vote du vote deux
ouvriers en faveur de la gauche qui
d'ailleurs fait que jospin n'est pas au
second tour et bien tout simplement ces
trois fois là dont deux fois d'ailleurs
sur trois avec une participation
communistes au gouvernement au moins par
au moins un certain temps et bien le
monde ouvrier et profondément déçus par
l'action publique on se souvient par
exemple puisqu'on parle des grèves et
des interventions policières forte de ce
qui s'est passé autour de longwy en
lorraine en 83 84 avec des mouvements là
aussi très violent et là c'est contre la
gauche
encore une fois que le monde ouvrier se
bat et après on a cette modernisation
comme c'est dit mais c'est entendu un
peu différemment cette modernisation
dans les bastions ouvriers qui a lieu à
chaque fois que la gauche au pouvoir il
a forcément les gens ne trouvent que le
compte n'y est pas chez vous il s'était
soldée par dont ils voient que c'est
histoire est emblématique quoi c'est un
pouvoir socialiste c'est fini qui
réprime des sympathisants communistes
n'étaient pas tous communisme cgt etc
comme par hasard c'est c'est troublant
puis fois ajouté quand même qui
électoralement c'est l'abstention qui
craignent aussi beaucoup de terre dans
le monde ouvrier sans l'apport corrie
mais c'est pas le vote front national
qu'est le premier la première réaction
du monde ouvrier quand même s'abstenir
aux élections ça c'est encore un auteur
mais est ce qu'à un moment donné elle
avait la classe politique n'a pas cru
que les paysans et les ouvriers
sociologiquement à lettres un électorat
en voie de disparition entre guillemets
que donc se diriger vers d'autres parce
que comment expliquer qu'on élude le
vote d'un quart de la population active
est ce que c'est une erreur stratégique
une erreur certains parlent de méprise
arithmétique oui vous avez mieux vous
avez pire c'est la célèbre note de terra
nova
si je vous disais tout à l'heure en 2012
où finalement les gens se disent
constate d'ailleurs beaucoup de ces deux
chiffres que j'ai là en proviennent
constate ce désalignement électorale des
ouvriers et se disent au fond faisant
l'impasse sur une population qui est
moins nombreuse et nous est pas fidèle
cas pas forcément même les mêmes valeurs
que nous et qui enfin s'abstient donc le
bon coup et qui disent on va recomposer
une gauche sur les valeurs sociétales en
faisant l'impasse sur les valeurs
sociales évidemment quand on dit ça
c'est peut-être très séduisant
intellectuellement mais à ce moment là
le français
n'est pas avec les mains protectionnisme
notamment c'est ce qui explique à ce
moment là le front national est fait et
basculer à gauche dans cette théorie car
donc pas la faute du terrain nous sommes
effectivement dans la
quelle est la position des syndicats
aujourd'hui dominique watrin on sait que
les jeunes sont moins nombreux
aujourd'hui à s'y engager comment les
syndicats aujourd'hui peuvent
représenter les ouvriers et les classes
populaires d'une seule voix
d'abord il ya une profonde division
syndicale qui est quand même un handicap
sans peut pas l'ignorer mais je partage
pas ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
lorsque on dit le
les forces de gauche c'est en tout cas
le parti communiste n'est pas vrai on
aurait abandonné les ouvriers il peut
vous dire que nous réunissons
régulièrement à rouvroy la ville où
j'habite les représentants syndicaux
pour faire le point de la situation dans
leurs diverses entreprises et les frais
c'est vrai qu'il ya une diversité ils
sont pas tous deux cédé aux journalistes
comment vont vous expliquer et on
s'explique y compris politiquement parce
que quand j'entends tout alors dire que
le front national aurait repris en gros
le programme du front national des
années 70 je veux pas me poser mais le
que le front national aurait repris le
les programmes du parti communiste des
années 70 c'est c'est une c'est une
erreur totale et c'est un contresens
total mais vous connaissez que le
programme du front national aujourd'hui
est beaucoup plus à gauche qui n'avait à
30 ans
plus tôt regardez ce qui est écrit ce
d'or le programme du front national
c'est aller vers le déficit zéro donc
moins d'administration - d'état et moins
de protection donc ils disent ils ont un
discours qui est complètement l' inverse
de leur programme et lorsque s qui parle
par exemple des salaires qui est quand
même une question qu'on met au coeur du
débat avec les syndicalistes avec les
ouvriers aujourd'hui parce qu'on sortira
pas de cette crise sans un relèvement du
pouvoir d'achat et bien eu qu'est-ce qui
ne parle pas du tout avez vous entendu
parler marine le pen d'une augmentation
des salaires jamais et nous c'est quand
même au coeur de notre programme donc je
je je dénie qu'un mensonge sur le
message c'est un mensonge voilà il ya
une présentation fallacieuse le front
national search sur le racisme pour dire
les choses clairement sur des sentiments
identitaires et veut se présenter comme
sociale populaire alors qu'en réalité le
coeur de son programme est un programme
libéral et qui n'est pas du tout celui
qui donne à est effectivement stéphane
sirot les les positions du front
national sont assez antinomique avec les
valeurs du syndicalisme
comment les leaders syndicaux aj styles
face au vote fn qu'est-ce qui prônent
ils ont de plus en plus de difficulté y
compris
manière interne parce que bien
évidemment parmi les syndiqués les
adhérents des syndicats il ya aussi des
électeurs du front national ça s'est
extrêmement bien que certains leaders
locaux du front national ont fait leurs
armes ou l'aviron sommaire dayan
qui était là oui d'autant plus que quand
on regarde justement les études qui sont
produites au lendemain des élections on
voit bien que le vote des sympathisants
des syndicats est de plus en plus éclaté
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus cette
hégémonie politique qui pouvait être
associé à tel ou tel syndicat à un
moment donné alors effectivement je ne
dit pas si c'était par rapport à ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure que le parti
communiste a abandonné le monde ouvrier
c'est pas ça
simplement je pense que la gauche a
délaissé un certain nombre de
thématiques je parle pas du contenu je
parle des thèmes et effectivement le
front national du coup s'est emparé de
ces thèmes pour les traduire à sa propre
manière qui est effectivement une
manière qu'on peut considérer comme
dévoyé par rapport au contenu de ces
thématiques telles qu'elles avaient été
portées par la gauche alors on arrive
bientôt au terme de ce débat jérôme
sainte-marie si les ouvriers et une
partie des classes populaires ne se
reconnaissent plus totalement dans
certaines en tout cas dans le message de
la gauche s'ils n'adhèrent finalement
que par dépit au message du front
national est ce que ça signifie qu'en
fait ils attendent des réponses
nouvelles un contexte nouveau je crois
que yoshi une aspiration à la fierté le
programme du front national finalement
si ça renvoie une image très défensive
ils défendent de travers français
entendu les français alors que le parti
communiste défend les deux travailleurs
français en tant qu il était travailleur
et surtout dans les conceptions de
l'époque de ces grèves c'était des
conceptions très offensive c'était à
l'époque le parti communiste permettait
aux ouvriers de se sentir les acteurs de
l'histoire et pas seulement des gens
qu'on devait plaindre eh bien ce sera le
mot de la fin merci à tous d'être venus
sur ce plateau merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi la semaine prochaine laurent
bazin vous proposera un débat sur
l'homosexualité dans le monde du travail
et moi je vous retrouve dans 15 jours
avec un documentaire sur la fraude
fiscale pratiquée par les entreprises à
très vite sur public sénat